like earlier
today a memory came to me that I I
played
aaru in a slow online game back in
2009 it was on ICC it was a 15minute
game I think they called the time
control
standard instead of like Rapid or
classical but for some
reason Hikaru was playing slow chess
back then he like he played the on ICC
known as the internet chess
club and earlier today I found the game
that I played
Hikaru he went by the username
Smallville I spent like maybe an hour
earlier like digging through I had to
log into the the internet chess club and
try and remember my old username cuz I
had like five different usernames on the
site and the username that I played him
on it was chest dude
64 it wasn't even like registered that
that name existed on the internet chess
club so basically the way I found this
game was I had to
search through hikaro games and filter
through the opening that I had recalled
and I I remembered he played
B3 I remember the first few moves too So
eventually I found uh I found the slow
game he played B3 and it was against my
uh my old account
name so I'm going to show the the very
first game I ever defeated
Hikaru this was back in 2009 Hikaru was
I think still 2700 plus maybe reigning
US
champion this is well before he started
a twitch Channel I think this is before
the existence of
twitch I should know what date or what
year twitch was was
founded but I think what people maybe
don't realize especially for those that
entered the chess scene in the last few
years is there's been an online chess
culture well before the age of like
twitch and YouTube and like even Reddit
before chess.com
too like internet chess club was the
biggest platform by
far and if I end up putting this on
YouTube I'm going to have to dig up a a
video clip I have some recording
somewhere on my hard drive of one of my
former coaches Demetri gurovich like
talking about hikaro and how he would
play on the internet chess club and like
talk with his fans and there there'd be
like sometimes 50 to 100 people watching
and also remarkable story I was giving a
lesson to G Bryce and EM G was playing
nak and all of a sudden when I was
supposed to leave gav says I'm playing
nakam I thought it was a joke I thought
he played a guy who says my name on says
my name is Nakamura and what he was
playing him karur himself uh first of
all I'm you know very grateful to Hikaru
who plays you know takes his time and
plays with am matur once in a while also
he has a big audience almost 100 people
were watching him on internet and he
talks to them explains them things
because his own fan club I think it's
very very nice um but it was a much
smaller Community back
then so anyway I wanted show the game um
I
was I was 15 years old I actually okay I
have a picture to
show this is
me playing
hikaro yeah for my home back then my mom
took this picture she she saw I was
playing aaro and thought it would be
cool to to photograph the
moment yeah I was like 15 or 16 I
guess
and then there's another
picture I think she took
after okay spoiler alert but after I
won um you can see like the final
endgame position maybe I was still
playing
though yeah this is before I had a
twitch Channel too I would just go and
play chess online and not broadcast it
to
[Music]
anyone oh thanks for complimenting my
posture
yeah there is no twitch chat watching to
criticize or compliment my posture back
[Music]
then anyway so this is also back during
a time I didn't really have a great
opening repertoire against random stuff
like B3 Bishop B2 so I tried to follow
normal opening
principles but then after Bishop B5 I
just like I didn't know the best way to
avoid the threat of take and take I
played the move D6 which is very
passive I think within a year or two I I
learned that the best move in this
position is
E4
to uh save the
pawn but yeah back then I played
D6 I think I I was rated around 2200
like Fay or USCF but also 2200
on ICC as
well we see hikaru's rating this is his
online rating so OTB rating was much
higher but yeah for anyone that wants
like a good weapon against the nimzo
Larson opening E4 is really really nice
cuz you don't lose a pawn A6 is pretty
much
guaranteed and most of the time what
happens white will do something like
this this take take you get the bishop
pair this Pawn is easy to reinforce
this bishop usually comes here it's a
happy
position anyway for those that miss the
announcement uh there's a
command um I'll be playing a tournament
coming up that
features Magnus and Hikaru so I'm
showing the the only time I beat hikaro
in slower
chess so
D6 um I think he tried to punish
me I played this move D5 so even though
I lost a Tempo I I block in this Bishop
prevent white from playing D5 and then
we
develop I con seeed the bishop hair for
some
reason but then it's a playable
position uh going
forward yeah I was actually playing like
decently solid
moves like looking back I'm not sure if
there's much I would do differently here
we trade
Knights and when you're playing a car
you're just trying to like hold your own
not make any obvious
plunders Queen G5 keeping the pawn
[Music]
defended and I just wanted to trade
Queens simplify
further and this was a long game but
basically what happened
is yeah hikaro tried to beat
me there was a lot of grinding I wanted
to trade Rooks but he didn't want to
and then it was very very
gradual white does have some space
advantage on the queen
side so I walked my king over there but
then hikaro starts grabbing space on the
king
side so it seems like I'm about to get
squeezed but I was still patiently
waiting discouraging
B5 and the eventually something
happens after a lot of non- pawn moves
we see F4 and then
H5 and this looks very strong as he's
trying to maybe create a weakness on H6
maybe open and then play F5 and attack
the pawn with the
bishop but I found counterplay play Rook
E4 and then
G5 and now this Pawn is maybe vulnerable
but then things get
spicy after takes takes he has his Pawn
on the H file which is passed my Rook is
actually stuck in the
center and then we maneuver for a while
like I'm I'm happy with a draw but he
doesn't want to
repeat and then yeah eventually we trade
Rooks and and he's trying to win he's
trying to use this each pawn and His
Four on three
majority but I have two pass
pawns and now we're going to see what
happens after King
F4 D5 it turns into a
race E3
B5 and it turns out that black is just
much ahead already threatening to Queen
and after Bishop F2 I play G4 already
threatening
G3 and this bishop is eyeing the H Pawn
and White's just a little bit too slow
B6 take take or take C6 and then that
Bishop E5 preventing
C7 and then
G3 it's actually kind of close towards
the
end I think this yeah if we look at the
picture and zoom in can see around the
the same position
so almost exactly 14 years
[Music]
ago and yeah the game ended after Bishop
C7 H7 Bishop
E5 yeah he played a few more moves he
tried Bishop C3 but I took his
Bishop
so anyway that was the time I beat
hakaru um I think over the course of the
years he's beaten me
well over 100
times and this game was the first of
maybe two or three games I've
won I did beat him that one time on
leest maybe once on chess.com
[Music]
what happened to the internet chess club
it still
exists maybe I can log
in
hey it's that sound that I almost never
hear
I've used to be accustomed to that sound
so yeah this was a
platform this is like the main place to
play
chess and this is not a browser this is
like a downloadable you had to download
the client to log into ICC it's called
piten there's also Dasher which is
another interface
and there'd be a command line
so like you can type in commands here so
the way I found the game was I had to
like type in commands like
search um his name was Smallville and
then I had to search the the opening
code there's these things called Eco
codes which are not used as much these
days and I it's a search
standard but basically when you type the
Search Command it will bring up a list
of games and then I found my old account
which I almost forgot about
here oh I was going to show the game I
played Magnus too but that that game is
on YouTube for people that want to see
this is my first time showing the um the
forgot game against
[Music]
taru yeah won in 69 moves nice